one in ten Americans say they feel
lonely or isolated from those all around
them all or most of the time that's
according to a Pew Research Center
survey last month Alex Wagner talked to
a couple of people who described what
it's like to feel lonely including a
doctor who wanted to remind people of
how serious the issue is loneliness now
is a greater public health concern than
obesity and smoking combined people
don't think of loneliness as a problem
or something they might they think well
I'm sand they don't identify the
non-owners but it's absolute work you
have to take it seriously the World
Economic Forum is taking the issue
seriously it is taking on the issue as a
global health concern yesterday at held
a session session in Davos Switzerland
to discuss the causes and effects of
loneliness New York Times bestselling
author Gretchen Rubin uses science pop
culture and personal experiences to
explore how we can make our lives
happier her upcoming book is called
outer order inner cone declutter and
organize to make more room for happiness
Gretchen Truman it's very good to have
you thank you for being with us I'm
happy to talk to you good a good place
to start so the rates of loneliness in
the u.s. have doubled over the past 30
years why is that well part of it is
that more people are living alone and
also being divorced or never married
that makes it more likely that people
feel lonely things like financial stress
feeling unhappy with your family life
feeling unattached from your community
these are the kinds of things that make
people feel lonely Robert Putnam Road in
2000 about Bowling Alone a death of
community things like bowling so if
those are dying out what do we do now to
create those senses of community well
it's a great idea to join or start a
group whether it's bowling or maybe you
want to have a book club or maybe you
want have a TV show club or you want to
go bird-watching or you want to
volunteer often it's easier to make
friends with people where you have a
common interest or where you're working
on a project together so that's a way to
forge those community bonds for yourself
when it comes to loneliness and
happiness or certain age groups more
affected than others well it seems that
very that the younger people and then
all
much older people are the ones who
suffer from it the most I think many
people would not be surprised that sort
of over 80 there might be a lot of
reasons for that but it's surprising to
many that younger people feel lonely but
you know they're finding themselves
they're figuring out the world they're
trying to find their place in their
community we're also finding that there
is an economic impact to loneliness the
AARP said that social isolation among
older adults cost Medicare 6.7 billion
dollars a year are we taking a proactive
look in connecting health and loneliness
you know more and more governments
institutions health care professionals
people are very focused on this it's as
bad as smoking it is a treat of
psychosocial aspects of our lives have
tremendous health consequences for us
for how our you know heart disease
Alzheimer's diabetes all in all kinds of
ways so it's it's extremely important to
look at for all different kinds of
reasons it's always said that money
can't buy happiness do you believe that
I only hear rich people say that I think
that money can't buy happiness but money
can buy many things that contribute
greatly to happiness so and if only then
the freedom not to worry about money is
one of the greatest luxuries money can
buy so financial security but then also
you know having an extra set of keys
even though these are so expensive today
or or whatever it is or to take that
trip to see a friend I know your family
in their family Nisour family members
call you the happiness bullet were you a
happy kid growing up but how did this
come to you that you decided you wanted
to spread the word of hat were you happy
I'm pretty happy I've always been pretty
happy but what I saw is that there were
I thought there were ways that I could
be happier there were there was
low-hanging fruit there were things that
I wasn't taking advantage of and I can
be a little pushy when I have ideas
about how I think either I or someone
else can be happier yeah I like that you
call your work it's not so helpful it's
it's so helpful not self-help what's the
difference it's not telling you what to
do it's just trying to suggest what
things that might work for you no magic
one-size-fits-all solution and a lot of
them involve habits what we do every day
watching Ruben thank you and we